President Trump at the United Nations
today where his America first agenda is
creating stark differences with world
leaders he's already butted heads on
climate change North Korea and Iran
it all comes before the president's big
speech tomorrow before the General
Assembly that's happening around 10:15
tomorrow I will be on with Martha get
you McFarlane actually to talk about
that and I know you cannot wait for that
I do enjoy seeing the president up there
with all the world leaders I love it as
much better than watching Barak Obama up
there at the same time it comes down to
this we have our boys right we have the
British we have the Australians we have
the Israelis we have the Canadians to a
certain extent we have the French
micronesia of course we have Micronesia
not my sole country understand why
exactly we have like Micronesia but we
have our people so it's more about
quality not quantity when it comes to
that so it's always been an anti-semitic
institution and they're always sitting
there with their hand out right and we
give them billions of dollars and then
you once we cut the check we have no
idea where the money is going and they
always vote against us but you want to
know why they're voting their own
interests people voting their own
interests that's very important because
I don't want the President of the United
States popular at the UN if he's popular
at the UN he's not putting America first
and that's what this is about the UN and
all these individual countries they try
to constrain America our energy our
military any time we're trying to root
out corruption or call them out for
their you know immoral conduct that's
fine but the point is they have a
history of raping pillaging of
squandering money and blocking
democratic progress throughout the world
so I don't like being lectured by them
and I'm sure the president doesn't like
being lectured by them either and do you
think the Chinese care what the UN
thinks the Russians care no one cares we
use them when we need them and then when
we don't need them we do what we want
the UN why I don't know if you agree
with this but I was thinking about it
before the show the UN you said hear a
lot more about them and really he's kind
of haven't in the last couple of years
it's almost as if they're off on their
own doing something nobody knows about
no well obviously the United States has
had major differences especially in
terms of the Security Council and the
kind of votes that have taken place
stark difference between US policy I
don't know that they're anti
Medicus my friend said I think that they
well I think Arabs are Semites but I
think that it is really ok so we have a
different issue but I'm saying to you
that I think it's quite clear especially
with Trump in the White House the UN
doesn't set us foreign policy the better
argument that I would make sort of
contrary to what we just heard from
Jesse is that this president has
alienated so many of our historical
allies especially our Western allies and
then of course you come down to his
foreign policy and you think hmm
didn't we just send troops to Saudi
Arabia we pull out of the Iran deal it
seems to destabilize the region had
repercussions he didn't anticipate you
look at what's going on in North Korea
they're testing more missiles you know
you stop and you think about the Afghan
pullout well we're happened to that I
think we're still in Afghanistan Syria's
on fire
that's our foreign policy it's not the
United Nations okay but okay that was
gone it's got the laundry lists way of
arguing no each one alone doesn't mean
anything but you put them all together
the under press on earth Korea you could
tackle each one of those who take them
apart North Korea that missiles they're
testing are its small missiles we have
peace with know what this is the analogy
I would use is that the UN is like the
college undergrad undergrads
and they expect the Dean the president
United States to appease and listen to
their complaints and say we'll do the
best we can
he's not gonna do that right he doesn't
he think he's not gonna sit there and go
oh we understand here take more money
even though you discriminate
discriminate against women and gays and
Jews they demand money and fealty
America from America and Trump is a
giving to him and also I disputed
whether or not he's alienated anybody
whenever I see him around world leaders
they either want to meet him or they
want to be him right they line up talked
badly behind his back but would think
they actually are pretty supportive and
acts on this list of support Canada
Australia Great Britain France I mean
that sounds like Rhodesia forget the
Czech Republic we'd love to check checks
they love the check yeah I think that
the media and the left frankly they make
a big deal about the president being at
odds with a UN leadership but the vast
majority of the world doesn't see them
as this glowy international body and
they're not the physical change
frankly that they were either supposed
to be or that they think that they are
the Paris climate Accord was obviously
symbolic and as most of their actions
were they filled a whole China
accountable we lost out economically and
there was incremental effect on the
climate they refused to condemn Hamas
and to respond to your request for
statistics on their anti-semitism last
year the UN passed 21 resolutions
condemning Israel and only six for the
rest of the world they adopted nine
resolutions against Israel and totally
ignored Saudi Arabia Venezuela China
Turkey Pakistan that are on and on I
think we should emphasize as well the
fact that the president this week is
meeting bilaterally with so many leaders
Pakistan India Egypt Japan etc which to
me is so much more effective and
efficient on the international diplomacy
friend he's meeting with South Koreans
and tomorrow he's gonna his speech one
of the thing things is going to be
religious tolerance and religious
freedom so we will see you for that